two truths 1 lie let's go not to
thousand truths two truths two units and
a lie
[Music]
Here Come three things I don't have a
high school diploma I used to run up
into the catwalks on stages and spit
spit wads down on people in the studio
audience
I represented the United States of
America on a soccer team when I went to
Australia my girl with B the catwalk
spitting spit was that that's a lie and
that's a lie right you would hope
no no why don't you go first I once was
offered a movie role via Twitter a
friend of mine made these pants with his
hands I was the lead in every play in
college and I like to say it was because
I was the only black person and they
didn't want to be racist I'm gonna go
with that last one I am NOT on social
media okay that's a false I have a
sibling of a duck a brother and a girl
well I've met your sibling duck so I
know that's true
well no that's a little lie because you
have two brothers yes she wins what are
we getting you get a car you get a car
I once slow danced with Elton John and a
party mmm
oh I ripped my pants during a
performance a jazz performance when I
was a younger kid my favorite dance is
the shopping cart what is it
can you demonstrate the shopping cart
that's not a dance that's how old people
walk Elton John was true no it's a lie
that was the one that was a lie
come on come on
boy Jesse your hey let me Jason no
that's all you go see game night
February 23rd 23rd she's hysterical in
it she's how I'll never work with her at
all thank you
[Music]